hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen there seems to be a bit
of a trend in the YouTube world vegan
youtubers coming out as no longer vegan
basically it goes something like this
so youtuber starts to build a really big
vegan following they create lots of
great vegan videos they talk about how
their health is improved how their life
in general has improved then vegan
youtuber comes out as actually eating
some animal products vegan fans go wild
they get mad they rip apart people in
the comments section they're angry at
life then other vegan youtubers make
commentaries and videos about the vegan
youtuber no longer being vegan and then
I interrupt the cycle and make a video
about the whole shebang
so everyone seems to be talking about
this whole cycle even awaken with JP is
made like a whole parody on it and it's
hilarious as so definitely check it out
out of hurtful things have been said
about me online people commenting in
saying nasty things about me there's
also a commentary online actually it's a
really in-depth commentary by vegan
earth and soul where she analyzes 23x
vegans stories and it's definitely worth
watching if you've got some time on your
hands and you're interested in this
stuff cuz I found it pretty fascinating
aggressive militant vegans who don't
have an understanding for basic human
psychology and therefore think that
shaming people in the comment sections
of YouTube videos is somehow effective
activism now before I get into detail
and talk about my own personal opinion
on the vegan community I want to talk a
little bit about some of these youtubers
major concerns and reasons for why they
are no longer vegan and to unpack them
from a dieticians perspective and talk a
little about what is behind some of
these concerns and symptoms so in a lot
of the youtubers videos that I watched
it seems like the story was that going
vegan at first seemed to improve on a
lot of their health issues and health
symptoms but over time these kind of
came back or they got really worse and
typically some of these symptoms
included things like bloating
constipation IBS and other digestive
issues so let's start there so when
you're increasing
the amount of carbs in your diet which
for a lot of these youtubers they were
on like a high carb low fat vegan diet
when you're increasing the carbs you're
also inevitably usually gonna be
increasing the fiber fiber is great and
of course it's really important for
promoting regularity and most people are
not getting enough fiber in their diet
however an excessive fiber can also lead
to gut irritation bloating and otherwise
just like general digestive distress
there's also a substance called phytic
acid which tends to hang out in really
high fiber foods like beans nuts seeds
legumes typically although really great
vegan foods out there but the problem
with it is that it can also impair the
absorption of really important nutrients
like iron and zinc this typically isn't
a huge concern in generally healthy
balanced diets even vegan diets however
when you start to really restrict the
types of food that you're allowing
yourself to eat as we tend to see in
some of these really strict raw diets
you run the risk of serious mineral
deficiencies next let's talk about
amenorrhea which is loss of your
menstrual cycle and there's lots of
reasons why women lose their period and
strangely in a lot of the kind of high
high carb low fat raw vegan diet circles
this seems to be touted as a good thing
I can assure you folks it is not things
like weight loss under eating /
exercising stress and nutritional
deficiencies or common reasons why women
lose their period also a lot of these
high carb low fat vegan diets may
provide a lot of calories but they don't
provide enough of those healthy fats in
order to sustain women's fertility so
early research suggests that women who
follow a Mediterranean diet which is
rich in heart-healthy fats tend have a
greater shot at becoming pregnant
not to mention basically all expert
recommended pro fertility diets
recommend higher amounts of those
heart-healthy fats the other potential
factor at play is the excessive amount
of carbohydrates which keeps our insulin
level at an all-time high
early research suggests that high
insulin levels force our pituitary gland
to pump it out luteinizing
hormone which interferes with our
ovulation and therefore prevents a
period important to note that this study
was only done on female mice so it's
unclear whether or not this can be
applied to women
however it's definitely something that
I'm going to be Keith my eye on as the
research evolves so next let's talk
about brain fog and functioning and
there may be a few things at play here
one is that early research has found a
link between a high carb diet and mild
cognitive impairment in older
populations which may potentially
explain why some of these vegan
youtubers described a lot of brain fog
and exhaustion also consuming a ton of
carbs can impact our thyroid hormone
because research has found that our
thyroid can impact how we metabolize
carbs this is why it's often common for
people to have both thyroid disease and
diabetes at the same time and just like
omega-3s play a role in our reproductive
health they're also really important for
our brain health as well so it's very
possible that a lot of this kind of
brain fog or difficulty concentrating
that a lot of these youtubers are citing
may actually be a deficiency in these
really important essential omega-3s
I also want to point out that while it's
very easy to obtain omega-3s in a
plant-based diet the type of omega-3s
that we find most predominantly in
plant-based foods ala is not very
efficiently converted into EPA or DHA
which is really what we want for our
brain health and you'd have to consume a
lot more ala omega-3s in order to get
the benefit which in a lot of these
cases they probably are not so next I
want to talk about some of the
psychological outcomes starting with
cravings a lot of the youtubers
described having these like crazy vivid
cravings like they were even dreaming
about eating steak and fish at night
this is actually kind of a common
outcome when we deny ourselves something
we tend to want it more that's true for
any kind of restrictive diet especially
something as restrictive as like a raw
vegan diet or a high carb low fat raw
vegan diet and for those who are
following a really extreme raw vegan
high carb low fat diet you know in a lot
of cases these people were probably
malnourished in a lot of ways even if
they were getting enough
calorically it's as if their
subconscious was kind of driving them
and forcing them towards eating specific
foods and thinking about these specific
foods and nutrients that they so
desperately needed and you know cravings
are both psychological and physiological
and I would think that in this case they
were probably a bit of both and that
brings me to the topic of orthorexia now
I want to preface this by saying that
veganism does not cause or threat SIA I
repeat orthorexia is not caused by
veganism
however as somebody who suffered from or
threat SIA I did find that listening to
a lot of these vegans talk and tell
their stories was honestly a bit
triggering for me because I felt like
those stories were very similar to mine
in a lot of ways a lot of these
youtubers described going on some kind
of mission to improve their digestive
health or your skin or their hormone
levels finding some information about
diet and then becoming so religious in
following the rules that had clouded
their ability to actually listen to
their body when your body when their
body was telling them that something was
off he was wrong I was there I know
exactly how that feels
so orthorexia is often described as
righteous eating it's not really a
disorder that's so much focus on
quantity or or how much you eat it's
really about what you eat and a lot of
these vegan youtubers describe kind of
eating really really large amounts of
their safe allowed vegan food to the
point that they felt sick but yet they
still did not feel satisfied I used to
feel the exact same thing when I was my
most sick I used to just kind of keep
eating and eating all of these alleged
safe foods and trying to fill this void
when what I actually craved were all the
foods that were on the bad list that I
wouldn't allow myself to eat and I just
listened to my body and honored my
body's needs all of those obsessive
thoughts would have just gone away now I
wanted to say that I am absolutely
confident that you can maintain a
plant-based or vegan diet without
becoming obsessive about it and I also
know that vegan youtubers are not a
great representation of the vegan
community at large this is
it's like not real life however there is
an alarming research around this one
study found that about half of patients
who are being admitted for anorexia
nervosa a very you know devastating
eating disorder reported practicing some
form of vegetarianism ultimately
veganism is restrictive so if you have a
tendency to allow rigid rules to
interfere with your daily activities of
life or your enjoyment of life then
you're running into disorderly territory
and veganism probably is not good for
you I know for me that would be the case
that's why I cannot really be vegan but
I'm just really happy to hear that a lot
of these youtubers are finding a diet
that works better for them in their
bodies so now I want to talk about this
call a culture that is obviously so
apparent and toxic within the online
vegan YouTube community what's upsetting
to me is seeing the disgusting
overwhelming backlash that these
youtubers receive and that they feel the
need to confess and justify their
decision to stop eating vegan with these
overwhelmingly extreme physical and
emotional health scares it's as if they
need to use these really serious health
outcomes as a way to circumvent the
online bullies and maintain some level
of respect within the vegan community
it's literally become the vegan trials
where you can be deemed a traitor and
sentenced to like a virtual stoning just
for eating eggs or fish this policing of
vegans bodies and diets which I will
also say is largely and mainly with
women don't we have enough policing
folks and this is happening within the
vegan YouTube community is probably done
with good intentions but it has the
complete opposite effect I think that
most of us humans share the universal
desire to improve the environment and
also we have a lot of empathy for
animals and we know that consuming a
more plant-based diet will help the
environment but this aggressive behavior
is pushing people away from even taking
a step towards the movement so you'll
always be there on the fringes and I've
truly believed that we actually could
have a much bigger impact
if everyone just did a small part made a
small effort to reduce their animal
consumption it's also pushing us away
from one another I mean eating food has
always been a really important way that
we bring people together and this
conversation is creating unnecessary
divides bottom line these ex vegan
youtubers are in a really tough position
that I feel so empathetic towards I mean
a lot of them describe having to always
put their morals ahead of their health
until one day something cracked and they
literally just can't do that anymore
they also often talk about how they
still really believe in the vegan
ideologies in the vegan movement however
at some point being vegan just no longer
felt right for their body anymore they
shouldn't have to lose their period or
become ostracized by their community in
order to justify that if it doesn't feel
right for their body that should be
enough I think this just proves that
there isn't a one-size-fits-all model
when it comes to a healthy diet this is
really why intuitive eating is so
amazing and so important because it
comes down to listening to your body not
some set of arbitrary rules that some
youtubers set out only you are the
expert in your body a vegan diet might
feel really great to one person whereas
a high meat diet might feel great to
somebody else where something in between
might be great for another person and
those things may change just based on
the hour or the day or the week or the
month and that's okay other thing I want
to point out is that I think we can
actually make an impact and reap the
benefits of veganism without being so
extreme both for psychological and
physiological health I thought it was
really interesting what raw alignment
said in one of her videos where she said
that a lot of people cite huge huge
benefits when they go vegan which likely
also has a lot to do with the fact that
they've cut out a ton of processed foods
from a not so great diet so the jump
from one diet to the other one is quite
extreme but we can actually get a lot of
those same benefits simply by
incorporating more plant-based foods
into our diet and more Whole Foods into
our diet and then cutting back on some
of these processed foods that a lot of
us know are maybe not the greatest
the outcome here is threefold one we
reap the benefits of those plant-based
foods two we reduce our consumption of
these heavily processed less
nutrient-dense foods which we know of
course is going to also have an impact
on our health and three we play a role
in improving the animal welfare and also
the environment by reducing our overall
animal consumption I want everybody to
know that the abbeys kitchen channel is
a space for all people vegans and
non-vegans alike this is really where I
talk the latest no BS science with lots
of great information on wellness
nutrition and food I hope that you guys
can all find your voice here but there
is absolutely no bullying allowed so
mind your own plate or go somewhere else
so guys I hope you enjoyed this video if
you did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment with some of your
experiences with bullying culture
especially here on YouTube or online
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye